because we begin tonight welcome to
Hannity with a Fox News Alert every
single constitutional freedom loving
American you need to wake up because
right now this is an all-hands-on-deck
situation you've got the mob in the
media these radical Democratic
socialists they have collectively not
only lost their minds they don't even
care about the damage they are doing if
they get their way they will destroy
everything this great country stands for
oh yeah the new Green Deal on top of it
all and breaking tonight we have major
new information that the corrupt media
mob is refusing to show you a lot
throughout the show
it'll take the full hour look at this
new photographic evidence exposing the
corruption of sleepy creepy crazy Uncle
Joe new inquiries tonight into real
actual collusion between Hillary Clinton
the DNC and Ukraine we broke the story a
while back you got to thank the
mainstream media mob and everybody for
bringing it back up new revealing
information also tonight surrounding the
AG's investigation into the origins of
the Russia witch-hunt the Obama led
counterintelligence endeavors also
tonight we will show you hundreds with a
beginning of showing you new documents
uncovered by investigative reporter John
Solomon that destroys the mobs
anti-trump Ukrainian fantasies now make
no mistake this is a defining moment in
the history of this great country of
ours we are now at a historic tipping
point if you are an American and you
care about truth justice rule of law
free market our free market economic
system our Constitution the sanctity of
your vote the very basis for our
republic it is time to pay attention get
engaged protect your country from those
that are hell-bent on completely
reshaping this great country with
nothing but more lies conspiracy
theories and one hoax after another the
American dream for our kids that hangs
in the balance the delusional Democratic
Party the corrupt lying media mob and
they're liars
they're speaking with one voice and a
full-scale coordinated effort to
disenfranchise the millions of American
we smelly Walmart shoppers I love
Walmart that elected Donald Trump and
for any person who has a functioning
brain it is now more clear than ever
left has suspended any fidelity at all
to the truth to logic to reason to basic
god-given common sense in their world up
is down and black is white and green is
purple everything they falsely accused
the president of doing we will show you
tonight they themselves are guilty of
for example every second minute hour of
every 24-hour day we have witnessed
non-stop hysteria over for an election
interference it told us it was important
Russia Russia Russia only problem for
Democrats it was always a lie in a hoax
in a conspiracy theory for almost three
long years in the end the Muller report
was a dud as testimony and embarrassment
for separate investigations cleared the
way for president Trump cleared him of
any wrongdoing so now the mob has ever
so slightly they just altered their
favourite hoax and conspiracy theories
and lies for a second round of
breathless hysteria and false reporting
take a look the President of the United
States and those around him during an
election campaign colluded with a
hostile foreign power I keep getting
asked are there echoes of Watergate in
this and there are there is already in
my view ample evidence in the public
domain on the issue of collusion if
you're willing to see it the president
used that opportunity to try to coerce
that leader to manufacture dirt on his
opponent and interfere in our election
you know Russia was interfering in the
election and they weren't doing it on
their own and he was in on it you know
the president once again has gone and
solicited foreign help for his election
effort
Roswell Rachel Maddow she's lying still
another conspiracy theory the world's
number that's why we call her Roswell
Rachel she believes any lie same people
same hoax same end goal destroying a
duly elected president and this has
always been about that one reason for
the mob as well it's not about
protecting the country it's not about
collusion it's not about national
security which we'll have more coming up
later in the show and
said from the moment Donald Trump came
down that escalator with his wife
Melania the left has been hell-bent on
taking revenge and impeaching the
president you that American people
elected and tonight with the help of
media research we put together what is a
comprehensive timeline it started just
two days after Donald Trump shocked the
world we were one of the few that told
you yeah it could happen was elected
take a look if he takes the risk of
going to trial he's convicted that could
be seen as an impeachable offense if
Trump were caught on a video camera
snorting cocaine in the White House
maybe with one of his children there was
at least a chance he'd be impeached if
he's not legitimately elected president
you're mine there are tools that
Congress has I don't see how that
wouldn't be an impeachable offense that
tweet fits the Republican definition of
an impeachable offense
I will fight every day until he is
impeached grounds for impeachment
it's an impeachable offense perhaps in
peaceful offense is impeachment the
appropriate remedy something through the
Congress like impeachment
all that maybe in future that's an
impeachable offense is that an
impeachable offense to you he's much
more vulnerable to impeachment a
potential ingredient of impeachment
where do you see in a peaceful offense
it is grounds for impeachment
potentially criminal or even in P chable
grounds for impeachment or does that not
go far enough in your view grounds for
impeachment this tweet alone may be an
impeachable offense
let's talk about impeachment impeachment
is on the table which impeachable
offenses bullies don't win and I get
baby they talk because we're gonna go in
there win it so you see an impeachable
set of offensive
it's an impeachable fancy if that's not
impeachable i don't know what is the
president shall be removed from office
on impeachment is it impeachable a
hundred percent is impeachable very
substantial evidence that the president
is guilty of high crimes and
misdemeanors grounds for impeachment
tipping point talk of impeachment
reaches a fever pitch on Capitol Hill
hat tip to our friends at Media Research
helping us compile that montage and when
you think it couldn't get any worse
congresswoman Maxine Waters yeah impeach
forty five impeach forty five oh she
wants the president now locked up and
put in solitary confinement so
charitable convicted no due process
great and her former colleague Barney
Frank is accusing the president of being
a murderer the blind rage of the left it
knows no bounds basic truth justice that
has been totally abandoned by the
Democratic Party and their colluding
partners in the media mob here's what is
at stake and it's pretty simple but
profound look at that map tweeted out by
the president Democrats get their way
the votes from all of that red on that
map will forever be tainted no wonder
why they want to you know get rid of the
electoral college and and stack the
Supreme Court rendered meaningless if
that mob gets their way and their
lawlessness gets their way after all if
this was really about protecting the
country if Democrats really cared about
collusion election interference where
was their history about Hillary Rodham
Clinton's dirty bought and paid for
Russian dossier even the New York Times
now recognizes was Russian
disinformation from the Birgit beginning
by the way we have an election in the
year in a year let the people decide I
think you're afraid of that
it's how green the congressman said the
best yeah he better impeach him because
we don't think we can beat him
I guess the mob only cared about
non-existent Trump Russia collusion
because according to a rare moment of
truth from Politico look at this real
collusion did take place in 2016 the mob
doesn't care about it Democrats don't
care about it does it has to do with the
DNC Hillary Clinton and yes Ukraine that
article January 11 2017 look at the
headline Ukrainian efforts to sabotage
Trump backfire political reports Kiev
officials scrambling to make amends with
the president-elect after quietly
working to boos Clinton oh they bet on
the wrong horse goes on to quote
ukrainian government officials tried to
help hillary clinton undermine trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aide in
corruption and suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and yes they
helped Clinton's allies research they
colluded damaging information on Trump
and his advisers and get this
even the Politico admitted in January
2017 quote the Ukrainian efforts had an
impact in the race helping to force mana
forts resignation van Singh the
narrative that Trump Trump's campaign
was deeply connected to Ukraine's foe to
the east Russia now also breaking
tonight big news from Capitol Hill look
at this from Senator Chuck Grassley
Senator Ron Johnson releasing a letter
to the Attorney General bar asking him
to investigate quote brazen efforts by
the Democratic National Committee
Hillary Clinton's campaign to use the
government of Ukraine for the express
purpose of finding negative information
on then candidate Trump in order to
undermine his campaign thank you the mob
now you have brought this issue up and
by the way didn't the Democrats spend
three years condemning any foreign
interference a collusion with our
elections aren't these same Democrats
and mob members bashing the president
over what is a completely fabricated
quid pro quo there's nothing in that
phone conversation with the president
and the new president of Ukraine same
Democrats the same media liars in the MA
they're doing their best to turn run for
cover because Joe Biden
yes former vice president he's now
facing tonight credible serious
allegations over what is a real quid pro
quo see the same pattern they accused
Trump but bounces back on them the
boomerang Biden is actually recorded on
tape bragging about him leveraging your
money billion dollars worth to get a
Ukrainian prosecutor fired who was
investigating his son Wow
watch this we're not going to give you
the million dollars they said you got no
authority you're not the president the
president said I said call him six hours
the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting money as son of a B now there is
a shakedown using your money
quid pro quo by the way the timeline
paints a much different picture look at
2014 Biden was appointed as Obama's
point person in Ukraine his son hunter
magically there after just a couple of
months after scored a lucrative position
on the board of verissimo holdings
that's a Ukrainian oil gas energy giant
he's paid millions of millions of
dollars but he didn't have any
experience and oil gas energy or the
country of Ukraine pretty good gig if he
can get it and recently Biden stated
that he never spoke with Hunter about
his business dealings but whoopsie-daisy
a damning photo obtained by Fox News
suggesting the joe 303 300 is lying
August 2014 photo shows yes then Vice
President Biden golfing with his son
Hunter and his son's shady Ukranian
business partner named Devin Archer
guess what also on the board of Purisima
Holdings and in March of 2016 John
Solomon reporting Vice President Biden
knew that Ukraine's top prosecutor was
investigating his son's work with
Purisima and he was even tipped off
about the investigation into his son by
the New York Times
that's when Biden leveraged the billion
dollars your money in US aid and forced
the Ukrainian president to fire a
Ukrainian prosecutor
Wow but according to the media mob oh no
no none of this is true
this has been debunked this is a
conspiracy theory coming from the
biggest conspiracy theorists and Liars
in the entire country
take a look trump is referring to
unfounded allegations that his Vice
President Biden tried to protect his son
by stopping an investigation into the
Ukrainian company that his son worked
for Biden and his son have denied all
wrongdoing and there is no evidence of
any and there's no evidence either Biden
did anything wrong but there's been no
evidence of any wrongdoing but there's
their husband he uncovered no no
evidence no evidence no evidence of
wrongdoing by Biden Rudy Giuliani claims
without proof unsubstantiated
substantiate unfounded unfounded
accusations against Biden hunter Biden
did not violate anything so why would a
vice president's want some Ukrainian
prosecutor fired thanks to our friends
at News Buster's org which also pointed
out this shocking statistic apparently
in just 10 days
you're lying corrupt conspiracy
theorists and the mob devoted 7 hours
yes their favorite new antitrump lying
conspiracy theory only 46 minutes the
Biden's obvious quid pro quo wonder if
the meeting I won't think about this I
wonder if the media mob would cover this
story differently if it involved Don jr.
and the Trump family or Eric Trump or
even oh look Baron's Trump for crying
out loud
we're gonna have a full timeline I will
lay it all out and get you DVRs
recording including Brad new allegations
tonight from China here's the bottom
line this story will be devastating a
huge boomerang to the mob the Democratic
Party and this is the end for Joe Biden
that's my prediction the DNC can now be
fully investigated for real collusion
they actually are doing us a favor
they're doing Donald Trump the biggest
favor and the president by the way will
not be removed from office his call with
the Ukrainian president there was
nothing wrong with it
zero no misconduct no quid pro quo read
the transcript yourself the only
favorite president Trump requested from
his Ukrainian counterpart during the
call was an inquiry into election
hacking from 2016 involving Hillary
Clinton and the DNC in Ukraine so let's
be clear
president the United States has a sworn
duty a constitutional duty to
investigate crimes United States has a
treaty with Ukraine in several other
countries like Australia Italy and Great
Britain that requires cooperation in
criminal investigations and that's not
all look at your constitution article 2
section 3 it states that the President
shall take care that the laws be
faithfully executed collusion happening
and the media doesn't care because they
can't plug in Trump with it its
president the president's sworn
responsibility it is his constitutional
duty to uphold the laws of the land
that's why the Attorney General of the
United States
oh he's traveled multiple times in
multiple countries to determine if
America's intelligence capabilities were
illegally used against American citizens
this probe otherwise known as the
investigation into the origins of the
Russia witch-hunt is reportedly ramping
up soon we will know if the most
sensitive weapons of intelligence were
turned against Americans and a sitting
president and a candidate will also know
whether or not the Obama administration
that these top Intel people were
circumventing US laws spying on their
own citizens outsourcing what is
otherwise illegal and that would be
surveillance of Americans to Intel
agencies and allied countries like I
said Britain Italy Australia we will
have so much more about the unelected
deep state bureaucrats and every agency
of our government it's only a few but
they're doing damage to the country
actively working against the President
of the United States he can't even be
the commander-in-chief under these
circumstances and as far left Trump
Haider Carl Bernstein even now knows
even his sources are saying that the
Attorney General is going to try to
deliver real evidence that in fact this
has been a deep state conspiracy like
the president has been alleging and we
have proved it ultimately this isn't
about the president Republicans and
Democrats this is about the safety
security and sanctity of our
constitutional system of governance and
also breaking tonight just moments ago a
huge win for the president federal judge
blocked California's law requiring the
President to release his tax returns to
appear on the ballot